[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance his daily behavior getting
weirder and weirder and weirder like
today his candidacy nearly ended by the
[ __ ] grabber tape he has now been
reported to have become as president
verbally and grossly fixated on the
breasts of a translator during a meeting
with the Japanese Prime Minister his
grasp of history doubted during the
campaign when he repeated the tabloid
gossip that senator Cruz's father was
involved in a presidential assassination
gave a speech suggesting most people
don't know which political party the
first republican president belonged to
his intellectual capacity questioned
during the transition when he reportedly
revealed he thought NATO members paid
dues to the United States he as
president reportedly directly demanded
to the Chancellor of Germany that her
country pony up three hundred and
seventy-five billion dollars his
campaign manager convinced microwave
ovens not microwaves but microwave ovens
can turn into cameras and his transition
team on the record asking about using
tanks during the inaugural parade like
this was made a 1962 at the Kremlin and
a guy on Fox News who used to be Glenn
Beck's vacation relief insisting Trump
told him he was on the shortlist for the
Supreme Court with all that I want to
ask a question I first asked a year ago
could Donald Trump pass a sanity test
with the help of a couple of
professionals in the field and using
only Trump's own words and actions I
scored him on an actual 20 question
screening test for psychopaths the most
you could get is 40 points the threshold
for probably being a psychopath
is 30 points Trump's words and actions
got him 32 points and he could still
finish life as high as 36 points since
two of his questions pertained to
criminal record and violation of parole
and there's plenty of time for him on
both short answer Trump could not pass a
sanity test then or now open book this
little problem is of course disastrous
in a presidential candidate though the
minority of roughly 63 million who voted
for him either did not note
he was the craziest nominee of all time
or chose to ignore it but in a president
the problem escalates to you know the
possible end of the world first the
thing with the purported invoice he
handed literally or figuratively to
Angela Merkel the thing that happened
just before this happened according to
The Times of London which has kept its
credibility more or less in tax in 1785
or which didn't happen according to a
White House that has already spent all
its credibility as of day 68 this isn't
hard to grasp and anybody's saying whose
parents were alive during World War Two
grasped it as kids because our parents
saw the Germans as Nazis and even they
understood why suddenly they had to
accept the Germans as friends
geographically Germany is essential to
American security
it is our symbolic front line against
Russia and Russia's primary geopolitical
goal since 1945 has been to break up the
German American alliance politically
Germany is essential to American
security because the last time we pushed
it away after World War one when it rose
again it was powerful enough by itself
to start World War two if we help it
with its self-defense even if we pay a
little more of the freight than it does
we are in fact paying for our
self-defense
instead and by the way the source for
The Times of London story is a minister
of the German government
Trump handed Merkel a bill for a
supposed shortfall since 2002 with
interest
this is nuts done by a guy who's nuts
then there's the translator story
Graydon Carter the editor of Vanity Fair
vintage Trump is not going anywhere
anytime soon a couple of weeks earlier
during a visit by the Japanese Prime
Minister Shinzo Abe a the president told
an acquaintance that he was obsessed
with the translators breasts although he
expressed this in his own fragrant
fashion you can decide which of several
vulgar terms Trump might have used about
the woman which bit of locker-room talk
the euphemism by which Trump so
cynically and successfully made his
boasts about sexual assault vanished
during the campaign the point is nobody
at the White House even bothered to deny
that story why would they Trump is
already disconnected enough from reality
to presuming
the right to talk that way now and
disconnected enough for reality but he
not only got the Prime Minister's name
backwards but the tweet in which he got
it backwards and called him prime
minister shinzo as if he wanted you to
call him president Donald that tweet is
still in his timeline and uncorrect 'add
as is every other crazy thing he's done
just since becoming president uncorrect
'add the obama wiretapped me hoax
blaming the Muslim ban airport chaos on
Delta computer problems reportedly
bringing his own fanboys with him to
applaud during his speech at the CIA the
whole inauguration crowd size delusion
the three million illegal votes delusion
the five million illegal votes delusion
praying at the National Prayer Breakfast
for Arnold Schwarzenegger ratings not
knowing Frederick Douglass is dead when
he's been dead since 1895 and what is to
me the surest sign of reality disconnect
the craziest thing so far possibly worse
than all the other ones combined if you
have not seen this yet please sit down
surrender eight seconds of your life
that you will never get back and pray
there is a God to help us and let Trump
fill you in on one of the great secrets
of American history about a president
named Abraham Lincoln great president
most people don't even know he was a
Republican right does anyone know a lot
of people don't know that
no hadn't heard who knew let that sink
in huge if true game-changer I'll just
leave that here life comes at you fast
mic drop are you effing kidding me
Lincoln the first Republican president
on Mount Rushmore face on the
five-dollar bill and on the penny only
president on the front page of the GOP
website besides Trump and Trump thinks
most people don't even know he was a
Republican and in context it's even
worse Trump made that claim to the
annual National Republican Congressional
Committee fundraising dinner hey did you
guys ever hear about this fella Reagan
that was the moment I thought back on
that sanity test and wondered if maybe
he could score not 32 out of 40 but 42
out of 40 resist peace